nouvelle émission de la série dans son
corps ça faisait longtemps aujourd'hui
on accueille mots de bettina mari qui
vient nous parler de sa particularité
physique à l l'aérophagie manifestement
rappelle moi combien ça coûte à se
refaire les dents dans les 1300 euros
pour d'accord non non comme ça c'est un
fait
[Musique]
mode et comédienne aux tris et youtube
sur sa chaîne perso et sur parlons peu
mais parlons monde
salut salut julien à travers un bon est
ce que tu peux nous dire quelle est la
particularité physique
oui j'ai un gros que j'ai des preuves de
digestion en ce moment non j'ai de
l'endométriose en trois mots tu peux
dire à quoi s'attendent les vaches alors
si je me trompe pas céder
tissu de l'endomètre qui se retrouvent
ailleurs que l'on d'omettre et qui n'ont
rien à faire là genre dans les ovaires
dans les intestins
dans le rectum etc et qui saigne pendant
les règles
sauf que ça s'écoule pas et ça fait
hyper mal en gros je crois
l'endométriose c'est une maladie qui
touche l'endomètre c'est à dire la
muqueuse qui tapissent l'intérieur de
l'utérus ce qui se passe c'est que les
cellules de l'endomètre migrer vont se
fixer sur d'autres organes autour est ce
que tu te souviens à quel moment tu t es
rendez compte que le coup qu'il y avait
un truc qui était un peu eh bien non
mais je me souviens que j'ai toujours eu
du mal et que je pensais qu'on avait
toujours mal comme ça pendant les règles
quand j'ai dit à ma mère j'avais
d'endométriose elle m'a dit oui
effectivement c'est vrai que tu avais
des grosses douleurs mais on s'est
jamais posé la question personne ne
m'avait jamais parlé de l'endométriose
donc j'avais jamais entendu ce mot j'ai
dû remarquer à un moment que j'avais
plus mal que la plupart de mes copines
il me disait c'est hyper costaud t
douleur de règles au point d'annuler des
rendez vous au point de rêver des
moments où je pourrai pas me lever mes
trucs comme ça on a tous entendu des
trucs pour dire ah ouais les règles ça
fait mal et je me disais oui
effectivement il est vrai que ça fait
mal aux lacets hyper douloureux et je
pense qu'à un moment il ya deux trois
personnes qui sont dit ça c'est pas
autant c'est peut-être pas normal que ce
soit autant l'endométriose touche
environ une femme sur dix entre la
puberté et la ménopause et provoque des
fortes douleurs au moment des règles
voire une infertilité toile spontanément
dans les premières années en tout cas à
aucun moment tu te dis peut-être qu'il
faudrait aller en parler
un médecin non j'ai toujours dit aux
médecins
j'ai hyper mal personne ne m'avait dit
peut-être c'est pas normal peut-être
qu'il ya un truc en plus non le principe
c'était de trouver un médicament le plus
fort possible qu'ils calment le truc
mais personne n'a été chercher un peu
plus loin c'est presque par défaut
c'était parce que c'est comme ça normal
la voilà et du coup moi j'ai grandi avec
ce truc là aussi bas c'est comme ça tu
as mal pendant tes règles et à le moment
où du coup on a posé un
non content a dit c'est ouais un
diagnostic en te dis ben en fait t'as de
l'endométriose sata est ce que tu fais
ça tu as fait quelque chose de partie
alors en fait comme j'ai tendance à être
un peu parano par moments
et de me dire bon mode c'est pas très
grave j'ai appris à me dire non mais
c'est pas ça c'est pas grave etc
jusqu'à ce que je passe l'irm même
pendant les 20 minutes de lille rennes
j'étais en train de me dire mais mode tu
vas encore tu perds encore ton temps
n'importe quoi on va te dire qu'il ya
rien et c'est comme quand tu as fait ta
fibroscope i comme quand tu as fait et c
est en fait je suis un peu tombé sur le
cul quand on m'a dit en fait il ya de
l'endométriose on à la yuma vaillant
mais là donc je vais aussi dit en fait
je ne suis pas folle parce que j'ai
l'impression qu'on ya un peu ce truc là
quand même avec les nanas quoi ça oui
bon ça va le cliché des hystériques qui
a ses règles et qui a super mal ben on
est un peu conditionné quand même dans
ce truc là est en fait en fait non il ya
une vraie raison médicale qui s'appelle
l'endométriose et ne provoquent ces
douleurs là donc j'ai pas été soulagés
spécialement les particuliers comme ben
si alors après ça justifie des douleurs
et tu te dis ah d'accord ok tu revois
tu vois tes vingt ans de règles et tu
dis ah oui d'accord ok ça devait être ça
depuis un certain nombre d'années du
coup parce que je suis incapable de dire
à quel moment je développe et ça le
radiologue le disais que ça faisait
sûrement très longtemps que c'était là
et que ça évolue mais ça évolue
lentement quoi mise à part ça je me suis
dit bon ben ok il ya un diagnostic posé
qu'est ce que je fais de cette
information depuis ça changeait quelque
chose tu as eu des traitements tu as eu
quelque chose pour battre les douleurs
n'ont rien parce que le j'ai apprécié ce
21 juin dernier le 19 juillet je tomber
enceinte donc oui bah déjà sa tranquille
il n'y aurait que pendant très vert mais
au niveau grossesse a pas de pas
d'incidence
non mais tu es toujours un peu tu as
toujours un peu des douleurs de raglan
simple parce que ça tire sur les
ligaments il faut que la place pour pour
se faire une idée de ce que ça peut
donner
donc évidemment t'as pas de comparaison
avec quelqu'un aurait des règles
classiques entre guillemets mais en
termes de en termes de douleurs à quel
point c'est handicapant pour toi et tu
es ce que tu as l'impression justement
le fait qu'il y ait des tissus un peu
partout à ce que tu as l'impression que
c'est quelque chose qui est diffus et à
des douleurs un peu partout talent
qu'ils sont c'est quand même super local
non j'ai quand même l'impression que
c'est hyper localiser ok sinon je me
serais encore plus poser des questions
peut-être que si j'avais eu mal aux
poumons à chaque fois que les règles je
me serais peut-être vivre à ce canal ça
peut arriver dans les poumons
c'est ça au niveau des douleurs c'est
surtout les
je sais pas je vais dire la veille et
puis les deux premiers jours on va dire
à peu près ouais alors pareil ça dépend
des mois je ne sais pas pourquoi en état
de fatigue en plus je sais pas
exactement mais
c'est handicapant au point de ba de te
bloqué chez toi et d'annuler tous
rendez-vous y compris professionnelle
ça m'est arrivé de d'avoir à annuler un
rendez-vous que j'attendais pourtant
depuis longtemps etc et on n'a pas le
réflexe il ya un truc je trouve enfin
quand je discute avec des copines il ya
un truc très féminin c'est que tous les
mois on oublie qu'on va avoir de règles
et en fait il faudrait ne jamais prendre
de rendez vous importants soit juste
avant soit pendant on va dire il ya une
semaine qui est un peu bancal et bien il
faudrait qu'on arrête de prendre des
rendez-vous hyper important est qu'on
arrive à se dire alors cette semaine là
c'est compliqué pour moi n'a pas
justifié pourquoi je veux avoir mes
règles j'ai vendu mes trios je vais
avoir mal je vais sûrement à nu ou alors
ça va très mal se passer
donc on va pas le faire pendant cette
période meiway annulé annuler des trucs
importants annuler des trucs loi
importants comme les boire des coups
c'est très grave
j'ai des images de moi plié en deux en
attendant que mon mec trouve nantes à 10
parce que moi je peux plus me des trucs
comme ça donc c'est vraiment enfin on
est sur des douleurs qui sont way cdc
des douleurs costaud c'est à dire que
l'on m'a dit j'ai déjà entendu dire
l'accouchement c'est s'aider douleur de
règles puissance 10 mais à chaque fois
on précisé à toi tu adores de maîtrise
as rome ita de puissance et 5
donc je vois et puis après voilà ben
bouillotte repos des trucs comme ça il
ya des traitements le problème c'est que
le diagnostic est souvent posée très
tardivement cette espèce de sursis avec
une grossesse mais tu t'en visage déjà
une prise en charge particulière après
franchement rien je sais pas j'en sais
rien parce que c'est chiant en fait que
ce soit on m'a dit soit il faut opérer
pour gratter tous les trucs soit on fait
des trous pour voir si dans tous les cas
tout va bien et tu sais la chance que
j'ai je touche de tout ce qu'on veut pas
du bois du sein c'est que j'en ai pas
dans les troncs way et du coup ça
circule c'est pour ça que j'ai pu tomber
enceinte parce que ça peut je suis
reconnue comme ce pays et du coup ça
colle et du coup ça passe plus quoi en
fait
et moi j'en ai pas je suis tombée
enceinte assez fascinant donc je sais je
sais pas c'est tellement chiant mais
imagine qu'il ya plein de nanas pour qui
sait ça l'est encore plus parce que
pareil on parle d'endométriose mais il
ya des degrés différents moi je pense
que j'ai un degré je dois voir le degré
cool et qui a des nanas qui ont des
degrés de premiers flocons
ouais c'est ça quand on cherche d'autres
même
même si ça a évolué un peu parce que ce
sera jamais aussi j'ai une copine qui a
fait qui a dû se faire opérer en urgence
parce que ella ella une espèce
d'hémorragie toute attaque et un sort
donc et lala des cicatrices un peu
partout et où là c'est pour beaucoup
plus costaud j'ai voyagé j'ai eu plus de
chances qu'elle est donc elle c'était
indispensable moi je sais pas je verrai
franchement si c'est pas indispensable
si je peux refaire un deuxième enfant
facilement et 6,6 et les mêmes douleurs
je pense que je vais faire comme ça
jusqu'à la mise en cause je pense parce
que le le le plus difficile à supporter
dans l'histoire c'est vraiment c'est
l'erreur et le fait que potentiellement
ça te fait une période de 10 mois où tu
vois là ouais donc ça mais c'est c'est
arrivé à rêver cette période là comme je
disais en plus des douleurs et de
s'organiser en fonction cette période là
en fait gilles j'avais lu un article
d'une nana qui se disait mais on en fait
on devrait comme nous on fonctionne par
cycles les hormones qui l'est
les nanas on devrait organiser notre vie
un peu en fonction c'est à dire de se
dire ok là j'ai un rendez-vous hyper
important je meurs début de mois la et
ben je prend du repos parce que j'ai mes
règles et d'assumer ce truc a en fait
c'est fatigant tu peux officier à les
ponts à rien tu as mal fait et c'est pas
du sang qui coule c'est un peu chiant
donc ouais cette période la whip it a
fait rien tu as peut-être même des
propositions pour créer un congé un
congé et menstruel louis saha deux jours
à sa lettre à prendre deux jours passés
un jour par mois sur dont gmail à 10 ans
en perd deux oui c'est ça encore plus
justifié pour pour le football est ma
copine et on ose toutes façons tu est
bonne a pas grand chose donc pas autant
assumer le gâchis
merde sert à rien est-ce qu'il ya
quelque chose que tu avais à dire sur le
sujet et que tu appelles l'occasion nous
dire non je crois que je crois qu'on
nous
nous apprend les filles un peu trop à
détester nos règles et à détester notre
corps quand il a ses règles de manière
générale et que au contraire on devrait
alors c'est facile à dire
on devrait arrêter de se dire ah c'est
relou tous les mois ça fait mal ça me
fait chier et c est de se dire bon bah
c'est mon corps qui fonctionne comme ça
d' accepter ça en fait et de se dire oui
j'ai mal etc
mais ça veut dire que tout fonctionne
bien c'est la nature quoi est encore
plus peut-être quand quand on a dans le
dos mais triodos a peu de faire la paix
avec mon corps ouais bah ouais ça a été
un avant et un après après voilà c'est
c'est hyper facile à dire ce truc de 1
bat on va on va arrêter de s'est pas
arrêté de s'en plaindre parce que c'est
important de deux goûters voilà de se
dire alors les gars l'endométriose ça
existe ça fait mal c'est pas normal et
c'est ça sert tout ça c'est important et
c'est important de prendre en
considération les nanas qui ont leurs
règles et du coup de potentiellement et
modifier le planning etc
mais c'est important de pas cracher sur
son corps je pense que ça ne peut pas
lui en vouloir en fête à ton corps ok en
gros tu peux en vouloir aux mecs il dira
salata tes règles mais ce match est
celui qui va pour le mieux
aubin je pensais à un joli mot de la fin
ok et ben merci beaucoup au delà merci
[Musique]